I had this idea for so long I'm still
working on it now that I'm bad like
growing up you know and like I said in
in church where we're all told we're you
know Sinners and you know and I have
organized religion has its own place and
I it works for some people but for me
there were just these really underlying
you know very sad messages that I very
much internalized and
um
and I'm still like that's one of my deep
core beliefs that I I carry around that
I'm that I'm working with is I you know
I'm bad
and
um you know so I I didn't really I
didn't
have a chance to I think fully be me
like without
trying to fit into everybody's box
around me that what they the idealized
child and not like the real child so I
think now I've
you know loving
all the complexities of myself is such a
challenge I have to allow those messy
parts of myself to
to have some play time
um because I wasn't I I don't really
think that that was and you know I don't
think a lot of people around me were
um aware of any of this but I those are
the messages I I received as a kid and
and very much internalized that those
things that happen when we're kids are
so influential and they might not always
be direct words but they're just a
feeling of like you know maybe even you
were going on tour but you were off like
playing with Barbies or you were like on
the swing set or something like that it
was like get back here and so it's like
you're bad because you're not doing
whatever you're supposed to be doing and
those things leave such deep deep
inference we obviously share the same
share a doctor which is super fun
um so I want to talk about that Health
stuff you know as you said you turned 40
and you know you work on those things
and psoriasis and I didn't know that is
it fixed and like what have you learned
about that what have you learned in that
realm because man that's a giant rabbit
hole oh yeah it is a rabbit hole and I
feel like
I keep going deeper and deeper down it
like every day
um yeah it's uh I don't even know where
to begin there I why'd you go like why
did you I called Mindy Mindy because I
wanted um I wanted to work on my
hormonal health so I had I had been on
birth control for years as so many women
are
and yeah it was awful and um one day I
decided to just take myself off of it
and I
my body kind of went right back into its
normal rhythms but not really like it
was it was kind of a yes and no I had
periods but then I don't think my all of
my hormones were balanced and syncing up
properly and
um no one had ever taught me about
hormonal Health at all like we're not
taught any of these things as kids and
so like I said I knew going into 40 in
this new decade I know there's a lot of
changes that we go through as women I
got on the phone with her she's so funny
she's like oh sometimes when I work with
celebrities she's got like I thought you
know I'm probably gonna get on the phone
with her and talk to her like for you
know 45 minutes and and that'll be it
and then literally I've been boxing box
with her like every day she's become
like one of my dearest friends and we
found our way into each other's lives
and I honestly I've never had someone
walk me through
Health in such a profound way and you
know it's gone from hormonal Health to
you know healing my gut to
um working on thyroid stuff like to
um yeah just figuring all the pieces of
the puzzle out and you know I've
discovered so much about my body that I
didn't even know and you know having
psoriasis from so young there's so much
inflammatory stuff there and
um no my psoriasis isn't um we haven't
really gotten to the root of that but I
feel like we're through other things
we're getting to the root of what you
know might have triggered that as a
child so
um yeah it's a you do open Pandora's Box
and you know there's days when I'm like
oh I can't do this anymore I'm getting
so close to feeling
um you know even better and I've come so
far like I actually keep a list of you
know of
little markers that I see of how I'm
hearing and I just started doing yeah I
just started doing that recently because
it's so easy to lose sight of yeah the
tiniest of transitions that are
happening and um yeah I've uh I've come
a long long way in eight months and and
I'm I'm still on that Journey so
yeah I wanna I wanna feel good in my 40s
I mean I had this goal I was gonna like
look and feel my best when I turned 40
and instead it was the [ __ ] opposite
and I'm like
oh God I mean truly the word the
opposite
um what is your what's made the biggest
difference well I have to say one of the
biggest things
um I have a oxygen chamber here in the
house and that has that's changed me a
lot
um I have I can tell the difference in
my brain
um I can tell the difference in my mood
um that is it's definitely a game
changer for me especially when I come
off the road like to just try to get
back into balance and and you know back
into normal life so it's um that's one
of the most profound pieces and I'm I'm
not we don't have a sauna here which I'm
really digging the sauna like that when
I when you start learning about like
I've learned about all the
neurotransmitters and when you start
learning about what does what and you
know know I'll be in a bad mood and I'll
get in the sauna and 40 minutes later
I'm like oh I feel a lot better like all
the serotonin and dopamine and
everything starts to like wait till you
get the cold plunge too I just finally
got mine delivered and I was in it for
about five minutes after the sauna today
and my body was um numb after that it's
45 degrees is what I've decided to set
it at and like then like as the blood
comes back it's like just blotchy like
your whole skin is like looks like
you've been sunburned but somehow
patching back together again but yeah
those things can be super powerful I
have a hyperbaric as well and um God
damn it I just can't get my ass in that
thing I it's it's hard it's hard you
know what the trick for me has been is
going in it even for like 20 minutes at
a time because that that that was a
Mindy trick man he's like because I was
the same way I'm like I'm so anxious in
this damn thing she's like just pop in
there 20 minutes at a time and so 20
minutes became like 45 minutes then 45
minutes sometimes is like an hour and
then I'm like oh it's not so bad so I do
it in the morning first thing when I get
up so I'm not like I don't have a lot of
energy running through my body and that
seems to be my key to at least getting
in there every day yeah yeah maybe
that's a good idea just get in there for
20 minutes which basically means
pressurize and depressurize right right
that's true you talked about anxiety and
I know that that's a part of your life
and
um like I'm curious like I think I feel
like we go down a pretty deep dive on
just the mental side of things and just
you know where did that come from and do
you do you know where where that stems
from because this is this is an area of
life I'm I'm really interested in and I
really want to understand
um better because I'm I'm a bit of a
first-hand learner and I've owned I've
had a couple couple times like three or
four times
actually about three times in my life I
felt true anxiety because I knew I
couldn't escape the thought it was like
a like you couldn't choose a good
thought it was like heart racing more
um and actually when I was doing such
heavy detoxing with Mindy oh that's like
Who full dropper fulls of that like
brain blood-brain barrier stuff a day oh
yes doing like suppositories ever
recital yeah Saito I was doing two full
droppers a day oh my God auditories
every night yeah and like every other
drug every other like pill and every
other modality including like red light
in the Hyperbaric and the sauna and the
you know like I just stacked a million
things and I finally hit a wall because
she said let me know how your mood's
doing and I've just got this like weird
resiliency and I was like fine I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine and then all of a
sudden I'm like I'm depressed yeah like
I'm like I was literally depressed and
so I kind of just stopped doing
everything but it's such a it's it's
such everybody pretty much everybody
will deal with it on some level but some
of course deal with it on a really
regular basis and I just have so much
empathy
um what's been your excavation of that
energy there's so many things
um funny thing about Saito I actually
you know I'm I'm of the thought if one
works then two must be great so right
and so I she's like just do like five
drops of side out to like you know slow
and then I'm like one dropper full and I
was in the fetal position because it was
all the that mercury it was like coming
out of me which Mercury causes so much
anxiety which I at one point had a
heavier Mercury load which was
definitely feeding that
um so yeah I feel you on the side oh
um I I think there's multiple sources I
actually just went to Dr amen and did
the whole brain skin how would you think
I was fascinated it was very interesting
it's very interesting to see my brain
um I have like zero dopamine going on
when I I'm not taking I take medication
um for
um it's called Vyvanse which is a
stimulant because at one point I I just
I basically get into these free states
of low depression and where I can't move
and so I take a very low dose of it to
get me out of it and he did a brain scan
one uh one on it and one off of it and
off of it I have like zero dopamine so I
think when my dopamine Pathways were
being created as a child I was wearing
those things out left and right and so I
my body just doesn't right now doesn't
create it on its own
um so it the the medication actually
really helps if you like this clip and
you want to hear the whole episode click
at the bottom of your screen